J.T. COMPHER WILL TAKE THE
AN EARLY GOAL FOR COLORADO PLAY.
LOTS OF TRAFFIC IN FRONT OF THE
NET.
TOP OF THELEHKONEN.
TO THE FRONT FOR BYRAM, AND THE.
MAKAR.
QUALITY MOVEMENT.
THIS ONE!
AUBE-KUBEL, HIS SECOND TONIGHT
ON THE FIRST SHOT AGAINST CAL M
TRANSITI KUEMPER.
DON'T SEE MUCH OVER HIS
SHOULDER.
HOW W GOTTEN BETTER AND BETTERM.
NOW SPENCE, THEY TIP IT AND
SCORE!
ZONE.
WE'VE SEEN IT A LOOVERPOWERED CN
WITH THAT SHOT.
PLENTY OF TIME FORT FOR MacKINN.
MAKAR, HE SCORES
BOTTOM.
CONSTANT ME FIND THE HANDLE.
MAKAR FINDS MacKINNON.
HE'S IN ALONE, SCORES!
HUMILITY AS HE WENT TO THEO HOL.
NICHUSHKIN DRIVING, NICHUSHKIN
SCORES!
SECOND TONIGHT FOR NICHUSHKIO
FADE AWAY.
PROTECTS THE PUCK, AND DANAULT
GOES TO THANGELES
KINGS.
TURNING THE HAND OVER BY
THAT ONE. ON A BOUNCING PUCK,
REBOUND PUT BACK BY DANAULT.
PHILLIP DANAULT.
FIRST SHOT, THE REBOUND, AND HE
SCORES